the world health organization declared
the coronavirus a global pandemic
exactly one year ago today can you
believe it one year ago
now look at this photo was taken that
afternoon in our broadcast center
shortly before we evacuated look at all
the people shortly before we evacuated
the building
one year later many of us still have not
returned to the building look at this
you can see personal items are still
there just as people left them as they
had to leave the building right it's
still kind of spooky
yeah it's sad to me i'm going to turn
off one of those tvs though
i think it's time after one year of
airing that's sad it is sad
in the rest of the country the gravity
of the situation had set in we checked
in with dr helen shu
an infectious disease researcher who
found a way to test for covet early on
admiral brett jerwah the former
assistant secretary of health
who was put in charge of covid testing
and david latt
one of the first coveted patients
hospitalized in new york city a warning
this piece does contain
some upsetting images cbs news has two
known cases of coronavirus so we have
closed our new york broadcast center
we knew at the end of february and
certainly at the beginning of march
that we had to prepare for an
unprecedented onslaught on the hospital
system the medical care system
with a previously unknown virus with
unknown transmission patterns
we were hoping that it would not become
like 1918
but it was becoming more and more
evident that there was
very rapid person-to-person transmission
and that the death rates were very high
it was really scary being an early
patient i think i was one of the first
1 000 in new york state we didn't know
what we know now about
how to treat covet the doctors were just
trying to figure it out
as they were treating me i was on a
ventilator for almost a week
and there were points where it wasn't
clear that i was going to
make it to unleash the full power of the
federal government of this effort today
i am officially declaring a national
emergency when the president declared
a national emergency it certainly put an
exclamation point
that people understood the seriousness
never has there been a virus that one
person
could not even get sick with and have no
symptoms and then the person right next
to them could be dead within a few days
and i just kept thinking i i
i don't i don't want to go i'm married i
have a husband we have a three-year-old
son
i wasn't i wasn't ready to go
probably the worst moment was when i
took over testing on march
12th and on march 13th understood that
there were nothing in the stockpile
there was no infrastructure
and we needed to build that from scratch
in a very rapid fashion
we're hearing from emergency room staff
who say they will soon run out of
supplies
during those early months when we had
shortage of ppe
it was a very difficult time we didn't
do what needed to be done
to increase manufacturing of those
products
and then also the shortage of the swabs
the tubes
all the things that we use in the lab to
be able to
diagnose coronavirus and it was like a
gut punch if we would run those 41 sites
at full speed for testing we would
exhaust 80 percent
of the entire ppe stockpile within the
first three weeks
ford motor company has just announced it
will produce ventilators to help
overcome
critical supply shortages they were
saying oh things are looking good maybe
we're going to take david off the
ventilator
and zach my husband just wanted to make
sure that if for some reason i needed to
go back
on would there be a ventilator or would
they have given it away to somebody else
we were prepared for small outbreaks but
we were not prepared
for an unprecedented global outbreak
of a respiratory contagious virus one
hundred thousand deaths our coronavirus
toll reaches a terrible mark
when we pass the hundred thousand mark i
think we
we really had lost hope at that point
that we were going to come out of that
i think knowing what i know now the
number of deaths
that could have been prevented is
substantial
we were really trying to look over the
horizon where we're going to go how do
we prevent the next hundred thousand
deaths what did we need to do
we cannot test our way out of this or
any other pandemic
i think there were many times where it
was hard for americans
one of the main things was the
clear inequity in health care delivery
and the disproportionate numbers of
deaths in black and brown communities
and i think it revealed a lot of the
things that were already there
and magnified them health disparities
have always existed
for the african-american community but
here again
with the crisis how it's shining a
bright light
on how it's unacceptable that is
we really have a sick care system we
don't have a health care system
and we need to fix it now and i think we
did make
strides towards moving towards a public
health system
one thing i think we did learn to be
optimistic is
we did come together in many ways
all of the support for healthcare
workers i remember being in new york and
hearing the cheers
one of the clear positive things about
this pandemic was how quickly scientists
came together to develop a vaccine
i think that to me was a clear sign of
people being very open and collaborative
and being willing to
all work together to do something that
was important for
the nation and the world as a whole
brought back a lot of painful memories i
never thought that we would still be
sitting here talking about this a year
later
no you thought summer falls certainly by
christmas
that we would all be out of it and here
we are and as far as we've come here in
new york yeah because those first three
months were
so bad in this city i mean just seeing
them again it
comes back so fast it's kind of scary
you know what we're not out of it yet
no we haven't been back in that newsroom
most people haven't been back to their
normal still over there it was tough to
look at that you see us on the air every
day but we are a skeleton crew so many
people are still not in the building
as chickens in this room i don't think
i've fully processed it yet no me too
no that's what i that's what i noticed
in watching this
was was i haven't i haven't really
gotten through but the good news is i
like how she left it on a hopeful note
there is a vaccine we've got three
choices and the sooner we get through
that
the better off we'll all be you've got
to get shots